darlin and Ella from data estates
excited what's up guys welcome to this
week's winners on a Wednesday every
single week I have someone on my youtube
channel who has succeeded in property as
a direct result of the training that we
provide and even through lockdown we've
had some one every single week coming
and sharing their story this week we
have an incredible story of Darren and
Ella and they're gonna be talking about
how they use the skills from the
property investors Academy and now they
own over a million pound property
portfolio they've got experience in buy
refurbish refinance commercial to
residential have just secured a piece of
land I'm a lease option so it's very
very exciting great to have you guys in
my home and welcome on when as Wednesday
you guys have got such a great story and
you know what as well people sometimes
think that if you are already a property
investor you don't need to go on the
training but you actually have three
deals or you've done three property
deals before you knew who I even was
start off tell me a little about that
and then Tim what happened afterwards
yeah so the three deals we had
originally were flips and I always
thought that was the way sort of do
property you buy a house you renovate it
you set it on and make some money and
that's what we thought was the way to do
it then actually Ella came in with a
house that we had up for sale at the
time it was a three-bed house and we've
done a lot of conversion yeah turned it
into a five bedroom
turn into five bed and we can put up so
we actually had it up for sale it was
online wasn't it yeah alright another
coming is like we're not selling the
house I said what do you mean not cent
house it goes were selling the house and
then I I've been watching this guy on
YouTube and he's going on about
refinancing and putting your money out
and reinvesting it so then we started
watching a YouTube channel and your
videos and that's exactly what we've
done and refinance then pulled all of
our money out yeah and that will be a
five-bedroom hate you might as well
that's awesome so basically you were
gonna sell it but you realized it would
be more efficient to refinance it
exactly yeah so at what point did you
actually come down to the crash course
John the Academy what was the what was
that what was that journey like
not that long ago was it yeah my thing
yeah the tail end of November last year
so yeah we came down to the crash course
we actually said if I should say this
but we said that we wouldn't be invested
in driver training because we've been to
train him perform we didn't feel it was
for us but when we were there we just we
thought that that it's actually a no
brainer because if we could do what
we've done just by watching your YouTube
videos what could we do using all these
other strategies yeah there may be no
z1z is going on the first day the crash
course we were straight in the back just
like straight up video and sign up
straight away so you something end of
the pressure selling we were at the back
like what can we do now before before
even got I know actually Alice say even
said to us do you know what I'm not
gonna say with you if you're gonna do it
you're gonna do it if not then yeah no
because we actually went to him said we
want can we have a work can we have a
chat and we want to we want to talk to
you about the Academy because the what
we got just from the crash course and
from the YouTube videos was enough for
us to make money wasn't it yes we knew
refinance in that first house and if you
can do that with no support what can you
do we've support say it made sense and
you've see I mean you've registered
signed up for done every single training
program that we do yeah I think we've
got one to go yeah the accelerated
mentor yeah okay were you paid for yeah
every single training program that we do
how is it being so far what's the
training being like Oh second for now
it's been amazing yeah it's got us to
where we are today it's as simple as
that and in terms of like your trainings
focus a lot more on mindset as well as
property education and it's just like
catapulted us into a completely
different headspace isn't it massively
yeah I mean yeah and the power team the
connections that we've made through that
we've got a property now that we're
using the builders through that network
to repair our properties thing and this
is just from sign up the Academy so
we've done
we've done so much just from the Academy
that I would actually say we do the
Academy again just to get that exposure
and the network and the power team it it
was worth it just for that alone
everything else that come you know
that's involved we've done business
together as well we have yeah and I was
doing a deal and practiced practicing
what I preach was raising some money for
it so how much did you did you lend me
in cash one hundred thousand and you
know what it's very very rare that I ask
people for money who are newer students
because of the conflict of interest also
there have to be a qualified investor so
they have to have so much in the bank
and there's quite a lot of strict rules
behind it so tell me the deal they tell
me how that works out it was actually
than no-brainer for us wasn't it
so is Alastair that spoke to us
initially and said would you be
interested in doing an angel investment
type thing with Sam himself we said well
what's the deal and it was 100k and in
return we'd get 110 K back in three
months so we're working out what hang on
that's like 40% per year so why wouldn't
we do it and at the time the money was
to say in our bank not doing anything so
we thought what a great way to sort of
kickstart us there's pretty much the
cost of the Academy done yeah that's
nice receiving end of loaning money as
well
so we knew how to structure Davee
agreements in the future as well exactly
exactly
because you've learned a lot just from
from doing that from from lending
because it's funny because I've lent
money myself I've been the person that
gives money I've also been the person
that borrows money because depending on
where you are in your property journey
depending on what deals on the table
suddenly because I teach as a property
investor don't have loads of cash in the
bank see if you've got cash in the bank
you shouldn't you should it should have
invested it but if you've not got cash
in the bank sometimes you can come
across a deal or an opportunity that's
so good and you like man I I need to get
some funds for this let me just who can
I call on who could I grab a quick
hundred grand from that can be in the
account within a few days and then I can
then give myself some time to refine out
some properties to sort to sort things
out so you've been in the experience of
where you've lent money you've also been
at the experience where you've built up
a lot of a lot of
probably you've got with your own money
now you're moving on to a situation
where you buy your getting joint
ventures coming to you wanting to do
deals why don't we just go through the
different property deals that you've
done the lessons the lessons on them
because you've done so much in the last
like seven eight months it's just been
insane it's been it's been a crazy time
as a net we've we seem to have crammed
quite a lot and I look back now and
think wow that has actually only been
eight months yeah have we done all of
that in eight months and considering you
sold your business as well in the
meantime and I've kind of stepped out of
my job to see property full-time so we
were doing this as a sideline as well
yeah both left two jobs you weren't
working for the minimum wage either no
we owned a sports car dealership that we
both set up probably of seven years ago
now and just build it up and up and up
and yeah we were quite doing quite well
both on six figures oh well
Darren had his dealership and I had a
vet physio mobile practice as well
saying yeah we do do 150k a year 170 the
year before yeah so you've now you've
now stepped from that and then your full
time in property yeah so we quit that
and said that's that's not enough we
want more we know we can do more and
it's interesting because passive yeah
what's so funny is I remember one week
when we spoke about coming on when as
Wednesday and you were saying I don't
know I don't know whether we're really
credible enough yet it was Amelia that
reached out I don't know if we've done
enough yet to go and win as Wednesday
and I'm like well hold on how many deals
have you actually done well we have got
a million pound problems he bought folio
and we have done you know we've got
multiple apartments and shops and I'm
like wow I think you're ready but it's
this whole issue of financial freedom
because in your eyes you say more like
we're not financially free yet because
we haven't got a passive income that
covers our lifestyle but then for some
people financial freedom 1,500 pounds or
2,000 pounds a month that's financially
free for you financially free is
something that's much much bigger than
that yeah we've gone the wealth builder
sort of way of them we rather than aim
for cash flow we were going to be
millionaires now
yes impose at because we folks are seven
said that's what we're doing we've got a
planning with sticking to it so it
wasn't so much about cash flow was it no
and like we said the the strategies that
we have picked like buy refurbish who
finance and longer-term deal was like
commercial to residential conversions
they do take longer so you're not going
to get that immediate cash free from
them straight away but you can get your
money back out and you can recycle that
cash and build that wealth so much
better so you're about building wealth
and it's funny as well because what talk
to me about the difference between
having a property portfolio of a million
pounds and being a cash millionaire
what's the difference yeah so at the
moment we've got a million pound
portfolio which is the properties that
we've got so we've got several of them
me yeah
rather than having say a million pound
liquid in the bank which is where that's
our goal that's where we're going to be
but funnily enough we actually did start
to go down the route of rent to essays
but actually stops so we've done a lot
the training thought why this is perfect
when we secured a rent to a same
Winchester yeah we did we Ellis secured
it yeah we actually gave it to some
other academy and members when we said
no we actually were gonna go down this
um BRR ruined the H Murray wasn't it
yeah we probably would have done it but
at the time you down was still in his
business I was still in my business and
we were still focusing on those longer
term strategies say there's only so much
time you have so we didn't end up doing
that but that's when we kind of really
nailed our strategy and thought what do
we want to do and thought we need to be
like that we need to level up yeah yeah
and that's where because if you're in a
situation whereby you're trying to make
a few thousand pound a month or you want
to get out of your job rent to service
accommodation absolutely fantastic but
with your goals and what you've figured
out on the Academy which was your goals
are actually to grow and scale your
wealth and build wealth red service
accommodation is only gonna give you a
little bit of cash flow you're not gonna
build wealth from that no this is it and
that's what we thought and because we've
been on the 10k month before we really
want to now level up to to get to
something bigger I suppose I think like
T when we went to the rent to rent
revolution it's really good to have that
information that knowledge anyway
because one of our commercial to
residential
versions will be sa unit so we still
needed that training and it's good to
know that we can do that and we were
going to pass that to a to someone else
via rent to rent so they can manage that
themselves so ya know we've done a lot
of the strategies sort of all together
thing people say to me what's the best
strategy but you have you have to
combine them so you turned your HMO he's
gonna be a abides by refurbished
refinance HMO yeah when you think like
the commercial once that's a commercial
to residential
prrr to sa if like it's all in there
isn't it all in one yeah talk me through
the deals I'm itchin so you've got the
buy-to-let that your mom was involved
with yeah yeah about that one so that
one how did you do this was this very
quickly after joining the Academy yeah
pretty much straight after yeah yes ed
we refinanced the house they were
currently in that one's is we're still
living in at the moment that's gonna be
HMO so we've done a three to five bed
the buy-to-let was essentially just to
sort of space help my mom out really at
the time when she was not financially
free or struggling with money but she
had lots of equity in the property we
thought well how can we go about doing
this so me and Ella sat down and had a
had a thinking a chat spoke to one of
our brokers which funnily enough we got
from your Facebook group just put a
little in you know who's a good broker
and bought that property with the equity
and managed to get a mortgage product
that would allow it because we didn't
realize but that's quite tricky subject
as well so we managed to do that and
that's just a bog-standard buy-to-let
and where is that that's an and over
where we live in Hampshire yeah
okay cool so you got that one which
which is which is great you got one in
Sheffield
yeah Bartley embalm oh wow okay
literally you guys are buying property
deal just left right and center with
that the one that you used the
negotiation technique and got an 8 to 10
thousand pound off the price yeah what
happened oh she ate 10 grand off the
price basically because of kovat it gave
us a little bit of breathing space
because we had an issue where it's it
was a leasehold property but we managed
to get the council to confirm that they
would sell us the freehold but we
couldn't get the document from them
during kovat looked in the town hall or
so they couldn't get to it
it can't have staff to get to it and but
it bought us a little bit of time and
our my argument was that actually the
markets going to drop and the property
wouldn't be worth as much as what we
were going to buy it for so we
negotiated down a yeah price reduction
of ten thousand pounds from from a fixed
price what was that how much did you pay
for the property originally ninety one
we were happy with ninety one that was
because that's what we've been saying to
all of the students it's like if you've
got any properties that you in the
process of purchasing try and get them
knocked down a little bit and that's
exactly what we did we heard that didn't
we install this let's do that got ten
thousand off so yeah and that that hate
that will be a it's currently a four
bedroom townhouse but it'll be a six
bedroom hate to mow and that would be an
all money out deal saying I see you
gonna rebuy refer bit and we finance it
yeah yeah combining the strategies yeah
have you got the end valuation on that
already if you've got I'd like a gdv
yeah so that would be one eighty
fantastic that's great well they've gone
in today yeah I've gone in this morning
mm-hmm and you've also talked to me
about the big fat juicy deal that you
bought for two hundred thousand pounds
as well because that one is a bit of a
cracker yeah that's a that's a pretty
good deal isn't it so that one was a
from Blackpool yeah yeah it was offices
and it's been ten to six apartments and
tea shops and when did you buy it that
one but a couple of months ago yeah yeah
so it was two hundred thousand purchase
with the legal surveys and fees and
stuff around about 250 we've got a gdv
of 650 so there's like a couple
underground profit in this deal it's a
cracking did a really really good deal
but funnily enough we might be selling
that deal so we've been speaking with
James arms from haven't we
yeah and he may have found someone the
reason being is because we've now got a
new deal which is a scheme of 24
apartments and this point is gonna make
you pretty wealthy if it comes off yeah
yeah this is
I mean is it's all going through as we
speak isn't it we thought we've got to
do this deal because it's so juicy so
you come from a really good healthy
juicy deal to another one straight away
I know the pain there because I was
talking about this recently on YouTube
at some point when you when you grow in
your portfolio and you're getting bigger
and bigger and bigger you're probably
going to have to sell off some of the
deals to fund the other deals in your
case it's all happen really really fast
normal normally people will start off
with single debts and then if and then
five years later they'll buy HML then
five years later they might start
getting into some a public conversion
then ten years later do a land
development you've done all this what
most people were doing a lifetime but in
eight months which is incredible so
you've put an offer on this big massive
deal that's been accepted yeah which is
JV opportunity you actually found them
on yeah yes it's 24 apartments in Oldham
Manchester so it's currently a care
homes that will be demolished and built
in fur 24 apartments very cushy so how
much was deep what are the profit
margins on that so we stand to make
combined 860 and we're doing 5050 with
another JV partner so your might just
what like about 44 20 yeah I mean when
you're making that kind of money on one
deal and one of the things I've said to
you is it makes just as much effort to
do a big deals it just to do a small
deal exactly 100 percent yeah definitely
yeah well although we still like the
bouncy one I don't know why I was so
excited about that it's just a
four-bedroom house that's going to a 6
but HMO so it's quite a not a smaller
deal but it's a normal deal but I don't
know why I was just really happy with
that one I think it's I quite like
property as an individual and I'm quite
like into my houses and that's just the
lovely old property and I'm still as
excited about that deal as the bigger
deals is obviously the money that
excites me about the bigger deals yeah
yeah which is inevitably why we we're
doing what we're doing so talk to me
then through I mean your you guys your
backgrounds growing up your parents
aren't like property millionaires no no
I grew up in a council estate yeah so
did I pretty much after my parents lost
a house that they built back in the 80s
and we actually
have to move to a council state so you
both from councillors dates yeah that's
crazy and both of our parents have have
done new builds and lost them yeah so
this is like why we've really channeled
we're doing new bills they and they are
being successful in it's working yeah
and also that's the reason we got
education as well because they made some
really expensive mistakes and we didn't
want to yeah follow in their footsteps
and hopefully we can help them all along
the way as well well this is it we can
put it back in and actually get them to
do new bills again but right this time
what were your first jobs when I left
school I was actually I trained to be an
accountant so it's done me well and and
then I retrained as a vet video because
I didn't really like the lifestyle of
being cooped up in an office all day
yeah so yeah I retrained to do that
which I loved but I felt like when I
started getting into property more
seriously you've got a kind of way up
what's more lucrative in terms of long
term future planning so that's why I
made a decision to just focus on
property full-time and what was your
first job I actually done a plumbing and
heating apprenticeship with my father
which I hated for ten years if I'm gonna
be honest I really did build it up and
then became a gas engineer I think I the
last job was like 30 K year and I just
knew that there was more I'd done so
many projects for other people and other
developers and other people that have
invest in properties and doing flips and
stuff but it was me that was going
around doing the work and and I always
looked and thought the guy that turned
up in the big Range Rover for example I
always thought I've got to be there and
I'm gonna be and that for me that that
was the turning point when I thought I
don't need to be doing this in my hands
I need to be working my head and getting
the people around to do the work and
making these bigger profits I've
actually brought when our ate with us
today I'm a bit car mad so we've got all
sorts of cars we've actually invested in
cars funny enough so this whole
experience and especially with the
Academy is to us to diversify and invest
in all sorts so yeah we've got an all
right with us at the moment but yeah
Range Rover Sport
ports and we've got hope and the garage
it's just an investment so yeah really
big into my cars as well obviously only
in the car dealership what would be what
would be your advice then talking to
somebody who's wanting to get into
property maybe they're also in there
could be a six-figure job and they're
wanting to get into property and get out
of that or they've just starting out
what would what would you what would you
advise them go for it to start with just
action yeah yeah I think that is the key
isn't it like they've been days where
we've just wanted to sit and watch a
film and watch Netflix but we haven't
we've just taken even small action like
every single day and then you're that
one step closer to meeting your goals
and like if you put the work in and
you've got the people around you you
will get there there's no doubt about it
just to go for and take action which is
another thing that we've been taught
from day one especially being on the
Academy is to take action and actually
go and do it and once you start taking
action and all of a sudden things happen
funnily enough and that's what we've
done over the last eight months and yeah
now we sit back and think wow we've
actually done quite a lot in eight
months
how have we crammed that in so yeah just
can't do it really and get some training
again both our parents lost new builds
years back do the training so you know
what you're doing which is what we've
obviously done and and go go and do it
go and get it and have a bit more
confidence in yourself I don't think we
had a lot of confidence we've both had a
big mindset shift over me she's been
important for us I remember standing up
at the rent to rent revolution and
saying that I was really anxious ringing
agents and that was when Alastair
decided to drag me up on stage yeah it
was like the massive cake that we needed
I mean what did you do on stage um do
you know what it went fine such a flash
I don't even know what I said I think he
just told me to explain a little bit
about myself I saw I wasn't actually
there in the room when it happened but I
saw the photograph of you on stage
you've lots of people absolutely in your
power hmm that was just incredible
wasn't and we got that from the Academy
you need to put that picture in as well
that's a good picture yeah so I just
stood on stage said my piece
and kind of you know you just sit there
and locked it up
I think we're property though it's this
twofold one you need all the knowledge
and you need all the information because
it is potentially very risky business if
you don't know what you're doing but
then you also need the confidence to be
able to actually take action yeah it's
been like 5050 for us as well I wasn't
it yeah from like the training we've
done all the training like you said
and yeah the mindset shift and jumping
on stage and getting the confidence even
to call agents and sin the go she ate
down on like fixed-price deals it's like
I never would have done that before
never that deal that you got 10 grand
off yeah that was fixed price change no
no we want some money up now yeah called
me up because I'm like the Hagler being
you know selling the sports cars and
stuff so we get some money off of this I
know we can what do you want me to do
well I was just like do what you gotta
do and I've always been the one that
kind of hides behind you a little bit
yeah Darren's much more of a people
person I feel yeah and obviously my
first I was background he's bad at
negotiation a hagwon like curries on a
TV and that are a walk-off embarrass I'm
I got hundred-pound off though yeah so
good and it's great it's great as well
to see your celebration side of things
as well because every time you've been
completing ideal you've been posting it
I've seen that either dangly keys
picture people they get upset with those
pictures people said oh you know you
keep joan pictures of you dangling keys
every time you buy a house
they're just haters man I just say some
will they see your picture and have one
we've got a few now so I'd rather have
the picture they're not for and it's
been because it's been great for me to
see I mean I know we've been speaking on
the phone and I've been we've been in
good communication we're just seeing the
pictures and the things that you've been
posting up and also where every time
you've been winning I mean at the amount
of times Darren's message messaged me
we've made our Academy money back again
we've made our Academy money back again
we've made our Academy money back again
with the deals I mean for me as the
person who created the property
investors Academy it's really satisfying
and people like you guys remind me why I
set up the training company in the first
place and I'm really humbled because
I mean I'm 29 so to be able to teach
people about property and have all these
different people but having their lives
changed and their finances changed you
know from my perspective it's it's it's
a massive massive honor it's quite funny
though because the first winners on a
Wednesday we watched we actually looked
each other didn't we said we're going to
be there one day yeah and our mindset
we're gonna do it so it's funny to
actually watch your videos and you
speaking about people to actually be one
of those students now which is amazing
but but then when you had the phone call
from Amelia you're like no no no I feel
bad about the now but it was more the
fact that we were like we wanted to come
back in six months and be like right
we're millionaires yeah you know when
you mean um now I mean honestly the
amount of people I've said this to you
already every time you have someone went
on when it's Wednesday there have been
multiple more people that I've also had
success but just didn't want to come on
the show which is which is which is
crazy people have their own reasons we
always always wanted to do it we just
wanted to come back in like six months
time for example we'll have to do
another one
what's your plan is then what your plans
over the next sort of six twelve months
so we've got lots in the pipeline in
terms of land sourcing and getting some
pie uplift on those yeah we've got the
land oh yeah so we've got a lease option
on eight detached homes that is going
through planning yeah so we've just got
um then we put the 24 apartments as well
which we've spoken about we're gonna
move out of our current house as well I
hate remove that one once the bonds you
understand because we paid for that cash
so we were going to do bridging finance
and we actually pay for that cashing in
didn't we so we can refinance that and
then have another big chunk to do to go
again so we're gonna have several so
over the HMOs I think and then also do
the land stuff you all end up selling
those HMOs no doubt you sell them
because you'll want to put them into
some castle or something yeah yeah by
car from no doubt yeah it's funny though
how the techniques are the same it
doesn't really I mean I know when you do
doing land development it might be a
slightly different beast
but the principles like
of doing a lease option agreement and I
little residential house that makes you
400 pounds a month and then on a piece
of land that's gonna make a half million
pounds it's very similar it's literally
the same there's no different from the
paperweight side of things and because
we're not as I was a plumber I used to
do the last of the three flips that I
done I was heavily involved with and
even the last foot that we done in
Andover you you know you were stripping
wallpaper and stuff and now we know - -
you outsource it and use our time wisely
to find it the next deal but they're the
same you know it's all the same isn't it
I think it is important to get your
hands dirty as well because we've done
that though haven't we you know the work
that needs to be done so that when it
comes to future projects you you you've
got that team to put in place do you
know where you know what to do and
you've been doing business with a lot of
Academy members yeah yeah and jayvees
other thing that we want to do and we've
actually done a deal with you Evan we
yeah with the with the money and the
lease option on the land yeah we've got
several of the Academy members that have
the message us constantly you know what
have you got coming up now anything we
can get involved in which is incredible
isn't it fun it's funny because what
first you were kind of you know wanting
to invest your money into deals and
people coming to you with deals and then
you were looking at them and seeing them
if it might work for you but now it's
getting to a point where by you've got
lots of deals and you've got people
coming to you wanting to invest in the
deals which is just a really good season
to be in it is yeah and it wasn't really
even intentional was it what that post
that you put up for the commercial
residential we just posted something on
social media about the deal that we'd
done already and from that post we just
had this influx of people wanting to
invest of us so we've created investor
list about you trying but you are very
active on Facebook yeah I mean
especially you a um Darren I see you
posted a lot of really positive stuff
and also whenever there's negativity
going on I know it's gonna be there
somewhere he won't be so negative stuff
he'll be shooting down or
it's if people but but you can because
you've done it well this is it yeah yeah
if you can if you've walked the walk
then why not and I think that's really
important as well and and that's
obviously come across well because
people message us a lot you know to say
you know there's to this let's do that
and even people are coming to us now
with their own deals saying we're not
quite sure what to do with this can you
help us and this is like eight months
after the crash course yeah so yeah not
sure what where we're gonna be in five
years time but well I'm worried to even
think about it I mean six months I can
just about visualize that you're gonna
be millionaires and you're gonna be
doing some really big deals five years
time I mean geez who knows what will you
say to be the best learning curve over
the last eight months I think it's just
getting a grip on your mindset isn't it
because that has just its transformed
things I think for you as well that's
really like Ella's boss now she's CEO
she's she's running the whole yeah - she
really is and it was always initially me
he was Annette you know from a plumbing
background I want to buy an old house
and move into and do it up and now
Ella's like yeah she CEO and that's come
from the mindset and the shift and the
jumping on stage and doing deals live
and you know you guys getting us to call
agents there and then you you didn't
even like doing that did you just call
out and now it's like only because I
know you've done a few other property
training courses around the similar time
as you were doing our courses not
necessarily paid for but some of it some
of the taste of stuff and you said that
one of the reasons you chose to do
training with us was because of the the
energy the fact that we do live deals
and you're awake in the room but that's
yeah but with that but but then
sometimes that's people's negative
feedback people say I don't like the
fact that you know you get you up on
your feet and get you call in and high
five in that was me before that was me
to start off with go on well I like the
crash course I like five minutes in are
just like hell I was like this isn't for
me yeah I did honestly and and you were
like straight involve burning and then
like 10 minutes as I am and 15 minutes
I'm like right we're doing this this is
it because it brings it out in you if
you've got it you've got it in like the
crash course
us me and Ella would just sound the edge
of our seats for two days straight 48
hours we just like that ready to go and
the prior stuff we done with another
company we were like drifting off at one
point when we it was a very textbook and
it wasn't much involvement and and the
practical side of it you mean you get
you got us calling people like that
crash course I was on stage that crash
was funny because we yeah that was it
Alice they made us deal like a task I
suppose and it was to find the best idea
on a justice sounded by to that yeah and
everyone at 20 minutes get yourself in
groups of three and and my team we found
the best deal and we were up on stage
sort of talking about that deal yeah and
I could that just wasn't me I was like
shaky and I was like she's shaking with
the mic cuz I can't believe I'm doing
this
but then got down and felt so enthralled
with that I wanted to do it again so
yeah 100% mindsets been been crazy isn't
it
the energy of the events is just
incredible and yeah because you do do
the live deals it does give you the
confidence because anyone can go to
these training courses and say yeah I'll
do that when you get home but will you
or but at your events you'll kind of you
are forced to basically you've got to
get on the phone and bring those agents
and you've got therefore you've got
people there for support as well so
everyone else is in the same boat and
you can see that people getting results
from making those calls and having the
opportunity as well so you've given us
the skills to do that task and then
saying do it there's the phone
there's the mic here's the time yeah
that's when you learn the most
what you gonna you can you can this is
the script this is what you say when
you're phone an agent and then say okay
I learned I know what to do now no no no
now watch me do it yeah oh wow I just
watched I'm a bit on stage now I really
no no no no now do you do it and that's
when you really learn when you do it
yeah man it's the difference between
reading a theory book and actually
getting in the car with a driving
instructor and driving and that's what's
not for successful enabled us to
actually go and do it I think and do
what we've done in such a short period
of time I don't know when the crash
course is gonna be back on though we can
win come again we go into more crash
course is 100% you do
in southampton soon hopefully hopefully
yeah well we did have one but we had to
we had to cancel it due to corona but
yeah i imagine in the next few months
crash course is going back on at the
moment we've got the samuel 365 which is
basically a lot of the training the
crash course is on there but it's just
the online version which so if anyone's
watching and wants to do some of the
training you can do that what will be
your final I'm gonna leave your website
you've got a website you've got and
we've got a new beautiful website so I'm
gonna leave that in the description if
people want to connect also you can find
you guys on the Facebook group yeah
you're always on there you're really
active you're really active oh that's
great for just questions as well because
we've obviously still got questions five
years time we're still going to have
questions and you can pretty much type
any question you want about property on
that group and get a response and even
the actual people brokers and solicitors
and all sorts so you can get the whole
often economy but going back to our
social media we've got Facebook page and
Instagram as well
awesome so I'll put that on the I'll put
that in the description as well so
people against and smash alive do more
JV deals yep more JV deals people have
got deals or if people want to look at
your deals they can connect and they can
talk with you because I think that's a
massive part of it as well one of the
things that I think is really important
about the Academy and just what
businesses in general it's about
relationships joint ventures you might
talk about the power team I mean who
view how's that what's happened there
well the Power Team for us so far is is
all been because of the Academy isn't it
so you think like well like I said the
the GC blackballed deal that was selling
James Armstrong just straight on it the
investment opportunity with yourself
Alastair brought to us Alistair's build
team Dave is there in the barns the HMO
today there's like his building we've
got the keys today it's a yes Sam
Hawkins this is done a contract for us
before so it's all been in-house which
is invaluable isn't it yeah and also the
support that we've had alongside the
live events as well so you have the
weekly webinar which has been really
really good
the monthly coaching calls so you stay
accountable so every month you would say
in what action you've taken and that's
been really really good and Rickon it
Anthony
call us up and how you guys getting on
and you always messaging out there and
yeah he's always always coming back with
the answer straight away it feels like
the Academy for me it feels like being a
little lion cub but then having the pack
of lines behind you that's the only way
I can describe it as you like you can do
it you know you can because you look
behind you like yeah I've got the team
to do it it's enabled us to do what
we've done so far we've never been
absolutely never but but at the same
time everything that's happened as a
result of what you've done you know what
you found you've done so it's a - it's a
two-way thing the I see the Academy is
like a toolbox but then you still need
someone to pick the tools up and put the
work in and utilize that really well so
we're grabbing all the tools of them
yeah exactly
you've got a stage making calls go in
the head with deals putting yourself out
there if you followed it brilliantly and
deserve every bit of success you've got
no doubt you've got a property portfolio
of over a million pounds no doubt you'll
be cash millionaires in the next 6 12
months that's definitely the goal yeah
yeah yeah and then we're looking forward
to to seeing you again on windows
Wednesday part 2 maybe next year if you
want to connect you can click with
Darren and Ella in the description link
below if you've got questions around
property investment post your questions
below in the comment box please don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to the channel turn the
notification belt on and we'll see you
next Wednesday for another success story
as we do every single week thanks for
watching
see you guys drive safe
bye now